foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hi this is the Paradox interactive
announcement show and we're gonna take
you on an epic journey through our game
universes a show packed with the biggest
news across the board
a new adventure game from hairband
schemes a new game from Rod humble and
the team at Paradox tectonic and
something huge from colossal order
and news and updates from a bunch of our
titles such as Crusader Kings Europa
universalis and surviving the aftermath
this show is for all our players out
there it is for you who take the art of
city building into Perfection creating
the city of your dreams it is for you
who want to see the great Empires clash
and change the course of history or
maybe just want to stir up some juicy
intrigues at a royal wedding
for you
who can't wait for the next big
adventure with mysterious secrets and
lethal discoveries this show is for you
[Applause]
the Chiefs are with us in the studio
today the hype is real and we can't wait
to share it with you but before we let
these lineup of games loose we're gonna
unleash another natural force upon you
the CEO of paradox interactive Frederick
Wester
[Applause]
[Music]
so first and foremost welcome to you all
who's logged in from across the globe
um we're super happy to to show this to
you today and um
I think we've all had a secret at once
that we've been dying to tell the world
but we just haven't been able to maybe
we've been prevented by the rules of the
stock exchange or maybe you've had a
project that just hasn't reached the
state where you feel comfortable enough
to show it to the world we know exactly
what you feel like
but here today luckily we have a couple
of projects who reach that stage so
we're going to show you a handful of new
games we're going to show you a range of
DLCs and updates for our current games
and we're obviously going to update a
couple of the games that we've already
announced but are yet to be released
but you're not here to hear me talk
obviously you're here to watch the games
so let's just move on to it and here's
the first
Trail
[Music]
it's complex only through Mass Circle I
got it
only a true Master exactly these fingers
are the pride of Cairo did I ever tell
you about the time are those famous
fingers done yet
[Music]
anyone spare a match
oh what do you know didn't even get to
use my gun there are other ways to solve
problems you know
well there are lots of solutions out
there wrestling punching oh and uh
running
[Music]
I'll plan to see again
foreign
what's up Stockholm wish we could be
with you but we're here in Seattle
finishing the game we're excited to tell
you what we've been working on we're
hair brain schemes you may know us from
our other games the Shadowrun Trilogy
and battle Tech our new game is called
the lamplighters league and the tower at
the end of the world
it's 1932 and a secret occult war is
nearly lost the forces of evil are so
close to Victory claiming the very
source of magic itself
the best of the best are all dead so
you'll need the best of the worst
thieves Scoundrels Cutthroats and
traitors to stop them just like our
other games the lamplighters league
features turn-based tactical combat but
unlike our other games this one adds a
real-time infiltration phase in real
time you'll Scout the enemy exploit the
position before deciding that things are
going to get loud
I like lowering the risk so I'll go
around and I'll pick off key enemies
that I don't want in my fight so I get
to pick and choose how I engage you can
just steamroll your way down one way or
increase your options uh it kind of
really depends on how you how you want
to play you never seem to run out of
like the depth of choice right and it's
just it's constantly surprising and even
when things look really dire you can
like snatch Victory from defeat you can
also snatch defeat from Victory but like
you know I do think one of my favorite
things about the gameplay is that
combinatory factor is finding those
combinations not just of characters
bouncing off of each other but how can I
use the environment what combination is
best for this Mission yeah compared to
another mission I really really
appreciate the the focus on storing the
focus on character and the ability to
kind of see these people change and grow
over the course of the game I like the
mix the mix of a problem to solve to
keep these characters alive while I grow
more attached to them every Mission
they're very human and that they don't
come together without friction so it's
Pleasant to watch them interact with
each other as they try and get out of
tough scrapes yeah we made it so that
they all have things to say to each
other both on and off the field you know
we really try to make them as much of a
like a team a reluctant team at first
but but a team as possible everyone here
are the best of the worst so to speak
they are Rogues these are not the people
you look to that save the world it is
about them doing what they have to do to
survive and doing what they have to do
to really just get ahead when you play
and you try different characters you
know I've said it before but it's kind
of a new experience every time
[Music]
foreign
thanks for watching and now back to you
in the studio
Monsters the lamplighters league is a
thing and it's coming out this year
we're off to a good start but we want
more here we go
a tournament a time for festivity and
games but also an occasion to build
alliances some even bloodier than the
Marshall feeds on display
an unhappy princess
can she find a champion
one whose virtue and Valor could restore
glory to her faded family name
or one who will protect her name by hook
or by Crook and
will per get revenge
foreign
[Music]
Alex it seems like you're really giving
the role players out there what they
want we are indeed this expansion is
full of things for the role players you
can take your entourage and set out on
the road go on a great tour across your
realm or set off to foreign Realms to
participate in tournaments among other
things wow that sounds like a lot of fun
what will you be able to do more exactly
you will be able to become the grand the
champion of tournaments by going to
various Realms and participating of
course there's a lot of other things you
can take out some extra taxes from your
vassals on a grand tour you can arrange
Grand weddings what do these all have in
common
intrigue intrigue well it wouldn't be
Crusader Kings without it right what how
can I use these sort of festivities and
events to my advantage you can for
example enact vengeance upon your Rivals
by inviting them to a feast or a wedding
and eliminating their entire family
or you can just show the world how Grand
you are and that you are the best at
tournaments all right well what will
happen exactly if I win a tournament
well winning is quite hard and there are
many other reasons to go there of course
uh if nothing else hosting it will make
you seem incredibly Grand and then if
you manage to win you will increase your
skills and uh you can impress most
people in the world all right all right
but
what will we wear what about the fact
we are introducing armor Through the
Ages and fashion specifically
um showing the early and late Western
ideals of the time
[Music]
interesting
also are going to drop some free content
with this yeah so when you set out on a
journey on a travel to far away lands a
regent will rule in your stead and of
course you can also be this Regent which
means that you have plenty of
opportunities for
underhanded and some peaceful ways of
taking over a realm all right when we
will be able to play this on PC so we do
not have a date yet but you can wish
list now all right well you heard him go
over there wishlist the game but what
about the console players
this spring the console players will
have access to the Royal Court
thank you
request to find the Paradox games of
tomorrow and there's plenty of up and
coming developers out there who share
our love for endlessly replayable
experiences and we have created a
special Mission units who are on a
mission to show and find the next thing
and
um this is what's next for Paradox Arc
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it's still pixel art
gather your party of pixelated bodies
[Music]
RPG Adventure
we'll explore a legally distinct
dungeons
fight ghastly
goblins or something
good marginal upgrade
epic and funny finishing your voice vibe
please please buy this game so I get to
keep my job
boom three in a row just like that that
was intense
lots of exciting games to look forward
to from Eric Dennis tell us what just
went on on the screen there so the first
game we saw was across the Obelisk the
new DLC called The Wolf Wars the second
we saw was macabellum and this is our
new Auto battler with Max the Mix yeah
and the third one we saw was the third
installments of Knight and permanent
paper three
cool so when will we be able to play all
of these cool games across the Obelisk
you'll be able to play on the new DLC
you'll be able to play on March the 30th
uh make a Bellum you'll be able to play
on May 11th yeah and knights offended
paper three you'll be able to play
tomorrow
awesome yeah
for you who just tuned in what should
you miss well we just announced the
lamplighters league a new game where you
will be able to still sneak and shoot
your way around the world
we discovered tours and tournaments in
Crusader Kings where the festivities
doesn't always pan out the way it was
intended for everyone involved
we have a bunch of news and updates for
our games so don't go anywhere and
remember we promised you something big
from City skylines and it's coming soon
but I can see the Fred is back and I bet
it's for an important reason over to you
Fred
thank you Paula
um so we've been asked questions what
our student Berkeley Paradox tectonic
has been up to and we're happy to tell
you that it's a new game but not only
that it's also a new genre to Paradox so
it's something super exciting and
something that is incredibly new to us
that we can explore and take further
but um not only we're going to tell you
a lot more about this game going forward
during the Spring but we're going to
start with a little teaser trailer here
at the Paradox announcement show and it
starts now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Life by you mark March 20th in your
calendar for the announcement event And
subscribe to the YouTube channel you
will have this teaser trailer there too
for you to analyze and dissect
now this
[Music]
wow you pulled us straight into the
action with that trailer Sonia come on
up here tell us about this expansion
well this expansion is the newest
European Universal is for and it's gonna
be epic it's gonna be amazing it's gonna
be deep and Global we are going to cover
Spain of course oh yeah uh also France
Britain the Ottomans uh China Russia
Japan so those are a little bit of the
countries that we wanted to change kind
of to make it more Global and more fun
how did you decide on this theme
well if you think about this uh these
countries are the most played by by our
players so we really wanted to do like a
something challenging something new
something fresh for them
um so we really wanted to change the
whole experience for them so they kind
of feel that we wanted to give some love
yeah thank you for that but if I'm done
replaying one of these great Empires
what new things will I be able to
discover there well we are adding new
mechanics uh new Mission trees so kind
of if you want to play with Spain for
instance you will have a new complete
set of of missions uh we are also adding
branching missions which is extremely
fun to play because you kind of decide
um the faith of your nation uh and of
course government reforms State and
privileges units of course music pack
all in we went all in for this you
certainly did but when will we we be
able to play it well anytime soon
actually so I just wish list it now all
right wishlist it is yes thank you you
here's a quick look at some more great
Paradox games coming out real soon
[Music]
of power
older than time has returned
free from their imprisonment ancient
wizard Kings come seeking lost magics
and new Realms to conquer turning all
whom they encounter by choice or by
forth
yeah
Strife
Champions arise
new unities are founded
and Powerful Arcane knowledge
unlocked
as gods and Mortals Clash the forces
Unleashed
will shape a New Age of Wonders
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
tell us the story about how we got the
Stars
please
again
oh all right I'll tell you the story
when they arrived those early days were
filled with hope and Marvel
all that knowledge all the answers to
the mysteries of the universe within our
grasp
have you soon realized the knowledge
came with a price the visitors came
seeking not friends
even allies but subjects
their true intentions became clear
then what happened mom
Spirit of our people could never be
broken
and eventually
we reclaimed our home
and forced them to leave
[Music]
will they come back
they are still out there
but the next time we meet them
[Music]
we will be prepared
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
here to give us more information about
rebirth the new expansion from surviving
aftermath is lost say hi hi welcome to
the show is it possible to come out on
the other side of the aftermath yes and
that is precisely the theme and also a
new end game goal for this DLC we are
literally and figuratively taking
players to greener pastures this time
yeah and I saw in the trailer there were
lots of greenery there there were
farming going on tell us a bit about
that the main new feature here is
terraforming so survivors can finally
turn the environment into a clean unless
once again and there's of course new
buildings and mechanics that come with
that yeah and I could see some month in
six monsters that looked pretty intense
what was going on there
it's never that easy with this game is
it no this time we have a new threat
called the blight that is a disease that
spreads throughout the world and it
infects people and animals alike and
also it turns the environment into a
breeding ground for these blighted
creatures so players need to push back
research the infected and that way
overcome the talents this time all right
yeah no you're never making it easy for
us that's for sure
but you're here with rebirth and you
know what I feel that it's we're coming
sort of Full Circle here because the
first time I met you I don't know if you
remember you were wearing a full-on
hazmat suit I can't forget that no you
were announcing the game at the stage
that pdxcon right and now you're back
here
with New Hope for the aftermath and you
even had a little plant in the trailer
yeah they become a full circle with this
DLC and it is a perfect ending for the
first season of surviving the aftermath
and I'm really excited about this DLC so
you really should wish list it now
[Applause]
big birthday coming up and when we
celebrate we like to throw a big ass
party and the party gets so much better
when we are sharing it with millions of
City Builders out there we're talking
about City skyline's birthday and the
awesome community of cities players
around the world we have saved a
birthday gift just for you and I'm gonna
hand it over to Fred Marina we're gonna
deliver it straight to you
thank you Paula Fred here and I'm back
and this time joining me is CEO of
colossal order Marina halekai and
welcome thank you so much Fred I am so
happy to be here and we have been
working together for the longest of
times right we have I I still remember
that demo you sent over to us in 2009 I
think it was so time flies huh it
definitely does and that demoed it said
something in motion right it did for
sure you could say that yeah and um
cities is turning eight this Friday
actually so happy birthday to City
skylines and is there anything you want
to add on top of that absolutely I think
we should have a look
[Applause]
happy birthday City skylines
I wish City skylines a happy birthday
happy birthday City skyline happy 8th
birthdays guys
Skyline
[Music]
[Applause]
I really love this game because every
time I played my creativity Vlog I love
this game so much that my boss allows me
to watch videos of it while working
because he knows how much it calms me
down one thing I love about this game is
that it finally lets me live out my
childhood dreams of being a city planner
it's been a great eight years and I'm
excited to see what's gonna happen next
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
game and what a community over 500 000
assets and mods created for the games
since we started exactly and think about
it five and a half million new players
last year that's basically the
population of Finland yeah yeah it's
amazing and we came here I told everyone
early on that we were going to spill a
lot of Secrets today and uh this is no
exception do you have any secrets you
want to share today definitely I have
been waiting for a few years to share
this secret with all of you so basically
I think for us isn't it time to take the
next step forward
I most definitely think so
[Music]
it's time to start from the beginning
it evolve into something new
[Music]
foreign
Envision a World created by you
[Music]
[Applause]
your chance to shape the future
[Music]
to create and inspire
expand way up high
and bring life to your creations
worlds to explore and pursue
[Music]
here
you are the Visionary
you
are the Creator
[Music]
make cities
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]